this lesson we're going to talk about
angles and angle measures so this is
something you probably member from your
geometry class but if not we're going to
review it here so a couple different
things we want to talk about and that's
it one is that when you have two
parallel lines cut by a third line
called the transversal you get these
eight angles right and there's a
connection here between these 18 goals
and that's you know some of the angles
are going to be congruent some things
are going to be supplementary so let's
talk about which are which and you know
what they're called so first of all
we're going to talk about corresponding
angles and the idea behind corresponding
angles is okay see how this forms like
an ex right there and see how that forms
an ex right there if you were to pick
this X up place it on top of that X the
angles that matchup with one another are
going to be congruent meaning they're
equal so to an upper right hand corner
is going to match up with 6 which is in
the upper right hand corner of this X
for which is in the lower right hand
corner of this actually going to match
up with 81 with 53 with seven those are
called corresponding angles they're
congruent than equal something
definitely important to understand now
alternate interior angles alternate
means that one's on the left side of the
transversal ones on the right okay and
their interior meaning in between these
two parallel lines so three and six it
fall in that category those are
congruent or equal four and five are
congruent those are alternate interior
angles those are congruent or equal now
alternate exterior angles extra muses
are on the outside so it's like 12 7 and
8 we're on the outside of the two
parallel lines all three means ones on
the left ones on the right so one and
eight are going to congruent two and
seven are going to be congruent that's
important understand now consecutive
interior angles consecutive means like
one after another right and interior
means that they're in between the two
parallel lines so 4 and 6 are
consecutive interior three and five are
consecutive interior this was kind of
the oddball the group these ones mate
the two angles add up to 180 degrees ok
they're not congruent they add up to 180
they're supplementary now vertical
angles you probably member this when you
have two lines across they form an X
like that the angles that are across
each other are going to be equal or
congruent however
want to say that so these are equal
these are equals that would be like five
and eight six and seven one and four are
equal two and three are equal and then
over here linear pairs linear means that
they form a line and pair means to like
a pair of shoes right so five and six
see how they form a line those are going
to be supplementary they're going to add
up to 180 so again another oddball here
ok they're not congruent that they add
up to 180 seven and eight those are
linear pair they out of twenty eighty
six and eight five and seven three and
four one and two they're forming a line
okay like a straight angle and it's a
pair meaning to so they're going to add
up to 180 so let's get into some example
CP and pause the video CD can do these
on your own and we'll go through them
together so this first example notice
what they're giving us it give us three
parallel lines okay so al is parallel to
M is parallel to n so you'll usually see
like a little arrow like this to
indicate that they're parallel or
they'll show you this type of notation l
is parallel to M parallel to add right
so all three of these are parallel find
X so what do you think your how would
you solve for x go ahead and pause the
video and we'll go through it together
well here's the thing if we were to you
know realize that Ella's parallelism
okay that means that all if this is 130
this has to be 130 these are what are
called alternate exterior angles just
like over here one and eight but then we
look at m and n are parallel we see that
these two angles those are like four and
six those are consecutive interior
angles these are supplementary so what
I'm going to do is I'm gonna make it an
equation 1 30 plus 3x minus 10 equals
180 so we're going to combine the 130
and the negative 10 which gives us 120
we're going to subtract 120 from both
sides of the equation so that gives us
3x equals 60 divide both sides of the
equation by 3 so you can see that X is
20 so that's the value of x now it was a
multiple choice problem you could try
substituting the values in for X and you
know seeing what what makes sense the
other thing that you can pay attention
to is that when you look at this diagram
when the two lines are parallel cut by a
transversal even though there's a
there's only two angle measurements so
all the ones that are like say for
example bangle one was 120
the ones litter obtuse meaning more than
90 those are going to be 120 all the
ones that are acute meaning less than 90
those are going to be 60 see how these
data to 180 so quickly by looking I can
see that this is a cute all must be the
60-degree angle right this is a
Toussaint must be 120 because there's
really only two angle measures even
though there's eight angles okay let's
go to example number two so here they're
giving us a triangle and they've
extended one side of the triangle here
and it says find the value of x so this
is 120 this is 48 this angle here is 3x
plus 2 go ahead and pause the video so
you can do this one on your own what i
would do here there's two different ways
to do this now one is if you remember
the exterior angle theorem for triangles
this angle on the outside is equal to
the sum of the two remote interior
angles so remote means that they're
further away and they're inside the
triangle so 120 equals the two of these
added together okay so that's one way to
do it if you forget the exterior angle
theorem you can always realize that
these are a linear pair they form a line
so if this is 120 that means the single
60 cuz they add up to 180 and in the
triangle all the angles add up to how
much 180 right so if we make an equation
we've got 60 plus 48 plus 3x plus 2
equals 180 and we can solve for x let's
see this is a hundred and 80 k plus two
more which is going to make that 110
right let's c plus 3x equals 180 okay so
make sure doing this right so that's 110
okay and subtract 1 10 from both sides
so we've got 3 x equals seventy divided
by three so actually equal to 70 thirds
okay can work out to a perfect integer
but that's okay that's the value right
there if you want to check your answer
you can put it back in make sure that
these all angles also up to 180 so again
if you need to review the different
relationships of the angles the
different whether the congruent or
supplementary with this diagram go ahead
and do that otherwise i'll see you in
the next lesson